yikes about those gas prices ever
thought you'd see this what's worse for
us drivers is when White House wannabes
pretend to rescue us from our misery
take senator McCain's five hundred
dollar tax credit to drum up interest in
the already popular but not yet
available chevy volt then there's the
mavericks big cash prize offering a 300
billion dollar prize for the development
of a battery package has a size capacity
Causton power to leapfrog commercially
available plug-in hybrids or electric
cars plug-in hybrids can get more than
100 miles per gallon so leapfrogging
that kind of performance would be pretty
sweet think McCain's prize will spur our
nation's geniuses to finally get it
together an invented ultra green car
well no because they haven't done it yet
Powerball even though a jackpot that
would make Powerball look like lunch
money is already being dangled in front
of them you see simply selling their
invention to frustrated drivers would
score them a gigantic payday it's one
dollar one dollar for every man woman
and child in the US would you be willing
to pay more than a buck for a car that
made a plug-in Prius look like a
gas-guzzling Hummer many less
significant inventions have shot way
past the 300 million dollar mark because
the free market is much more generous
than any candidate post-it notes have
captured billions in sales Ray Kroc made
his billions with burgers and this 23
year old became the world's youngest
billionaire by getting Facebook users to
super poke each other online if stuff
like this makes so much dough imagine
the jackpot in store for the person who
does eventually mass produce a 200 miles
per gallon car yep McCain's 300 million
dollar prize is chump change and it
makes him sound nearly as out of touch
as the infamous villain who threatened
to hold the whole world hostage for
1 million dollars